lo que hemos representado aquí es una
vía de transducción de señales que
comienza con la toxina del cólera y
hemos hablado de las vías de
transducción de señales en otros vídeos
pero en realidad la idea es que tenemos
moléculas fuera de la célula que
interactúan con receptores en la
superficie de la célula que crean una
reacción en cadena completa de eventos
que harán que esa célula haga algo
entonces si estuvieran en la
desafortunada situación y esto no es
algo que desearía para nadie si tuvieran
la bacteria del cólera en sus entrañas
digamos que esta es la bacteria del
cólera lo que sucedería es que las
bacterias del cólera en sus intestinos
liberarían la toxina del cólera y aquí
está representado de manera muy
abstracta por un círculo encima de un
triángulo en realidad no se ve así es un
complejo de proteínas con varias
subunidades de proteínas se dibuja de
esta manera para que podamos pensar en
este triángulo que interactúa con este
receptor en la célula epitelial lo que
sucederá es que esta toxina del cólera
entera
lo hará con este receptor de ganglios y
dos no tienen que conocer los detalles
en realidad sólo deben tener una idea de
lo que está pasando y una vez que sucede
cuando vean estas flechas en estas vías
de transducción significa que se activa
el siguiente paso es decir que se va a
promover el siguiente paso o que va a
hacer que sea más probable que suceda
pero lo que sucede es que una vez que
esto ha interactuado la parte a de la
subunidad entra y ahora interactúa con
una proteína g no es necesario que
conozcan todos los detalles pero las
proteínas que son algo que verán en
muchas vías de transducción de señales
no sólo hay una proteína g hay toda una
familia de proteínas llamadas proteínas
que pueden verlos como interruptores
moleculares que se activan y se
desactivan según la forma en la que
interactúan con otras moléculas además
sus formas cambian y por lo tanto pueden
activarse o desactivarse entonces si
seguimos estas flechas podemos ver lo
que eventualmente sucede y no tienen que
saber todos los detalles
aquí podemos ver que en algún momento
nos llevan al adenilato ciclasa luego a
la mp cíclica y luego se involucra a la
proteína quinasa pero el resultado final
de esta vía es que estos iones se
liberan de esta célula epitelial eso
hace que el agua salga de la célula y
eso es lo que causa la diarrea así que
la toxina obtiene sus células
intestinales y hace que sus células
intestinales comiencen a liberar agua
por lo que tendrás una diarrea muy muy
grave de modo que ese es el panorama
general pero ahora podemos pensar en lo
que podría suceder en ciertas
situaciones digamos que esta célula
epitelial de alguna manera tuvo una
mutación por lo que su receptor de
ganglios y dos no interactúa bien con la
subunidad ve con la toxina del cólera
qué pasaría entonces pausa en el vídeo y
tratan de pensar en esto de acuerdo por
alguna razón esta célula epitelial tenía
un receptor de ganglios y dos que era un
poco diferente y no podía interactuar
tan eficientemente con la toxina del
cólera
bueno en esta situación esta activación
no estaría ocurriendo o al menos no
estaría sucediendo tan eficientemente
por lo tanto alguien con este tipo de
receptor de ganglios idos podría tener
otros efectos secundarios negativos pero
en realidad no tendría una diarrea tan
grave provocada por la toxina del cólera
porque esta vía de transducción de
señales no estaría sucediendo o al menos
no sucedería tan fuerte pero por otro
lado resulta que hay moléculas que
pueden interrumpir esta vía de
transducción de señales entonces aquí
tenemos un receptor opioide y si se
activa entonces activará otra proteína g
este es diferente al que está aquí pero
es parte de la misma familia y cuando
veis este tipo de cosas cuando ves una
línea con esta cabeza plana en lugar de
una flecha significa que se está
inhibiendo ese proceso entonces por
ejemplo este receptor opioide es
receptivo a una molécula conocida como
encefalinas no es necesario que te
aprendas todo eso pero
si debes saber es que tienes esta
molécula fuera de la célula que puede
interactuar con el receptor opioide que
luego activará una proteína g y lo
interesante es que esta proteína g es en
realidad un inhibidor de este paso que
tenemos aquí entonces si tienes cólera y
toxinas de köhler en el intestino pero
también se expone en las células
epiteliales a la encefalinas eso podría
hacer que la diarrea sea menos grave
porque si esto se interrumpe o al menos
si se inhibe entonces el resto de esta
vía no sucederá o no sucederá tan fuerte
de aquí surge otra pregunta si hubiera
alguna mutación en el receptor opioide
lo que no sería tan bueno en la unión
con la encefalinas cuál sería el
resultado final bueno si el receptor
opioide de alguna manera no es tan
receptivo a la encefalinas entonces la
encefalinas no será tan efectiva para
detener esta vía de transducción de
señales porque la encefalinas no podrá
unirse a ese receptor opioide
por lo tanto esta inhibición no ocurre
sino que sucede la vía de transducción
regular de la toxina del cólera lo que
resulta en diarrea así que los dejaré
ahí lo más importante aquí es que cuando
ves estas vías puedes ver las flechas
como activación o que te llevan al
siguiente paso y estas líneas con estas
cabezas planas se refieren a inhibición
y es muy común especialmente si eres un
científico que puedas construir estas
vías pero también tendrás algunas
preguntas como por ejemplo si hay una
mutación en algo que activa la vía que
pasará bueno si hay una mutación la vía
no ocurrirá completamente o incluso no
sucederá
pero si hay una mutación en algo que
inhibe la vía que pasa bueno si hay una
mutación que hace menos funcional algo
que inhibe regularmente una vía entonces
la vía se inhibirá menos hasta el
próximo vídeo